surreal und gespenstisch so nennt
kanzlerin merkel die lage bei ihrem
besuch in den flutgebieten
die zahl der toten steigt weiter auf
inzwischen 1 159 und noch mehr regen im
berchtesgadener land in bayern gilt der
katastrophenfall hänge rutschten ab
flüsse treten über die ufer
ein zeichen des klimawandels im
zdf-sommerinterview sieht afg chef jörg
leuten keinen klaren zusammenhang
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den kunden da von mir noch mehr tote
viele verletzte zum teil weder strom
noch telefon die lage in den
flutgebieten bleibt katastrophal
die kanzlerin versprach bei ihrem besuch
an der aa in rheinland-pfalz schnelle
hilfe in dreistelliger millionenhöhe
und sie betonte deutschland müsse sich
sputen im kampf gegen den klimawandel
beginnen wir im kreis ahrweiler
allein hier wurden bislang 110 leichen
gefunden in trümmern und schlamm
besonders zerstört haben die
wassermassen die orte bad neuenahr
ahrweiler unschuld noch immer werden
viele menschen vermisst
die genaue zahl ist unklar marion geiger
berichtet in den häusern die noch stabil
stehen den schuld räumen die menschen
auf alles muss raus
die trümmer die ihre möbel waren ihre
sachen der schwere dicke schlamm
wir hoffen dass die politik sieht was
hier passiert ist das wirklich alles
zerstört ist und das ist dem
entsprechenden umfangreiches
rettungspaket geben wird für die
menschen war das ist schon wirklich
traurig wenn man sich hier umschaut
am mittag kommen die kanzlerinnen das
schwer zerstörte dorf angela merkel
spricht danach von einer sehr realen
gespenstischen situation
es ist erschreckend ich würde fast sagen
die deutsche sprache kennt kaum worte
für die verwüstung die angerichtet ist
merkel verspricht den betroffenen
schnelle hilfe und langen atem beim
wiederaufbau die schäden sind
unvorstellbar groß diese flut wird für
die menschen schon hinterlassen und
haben die man nie vergisst
die nicht bewältigen sind
im gesamten landkreis ahrweiler stehen
zahllose existenzen auf dem spiel
in der stadt ahrweiler sind ganze
straßenzüge zerstört peter weber hatte
hier sein geschäft es lief gut trotz
corona dann kam die flut weber ist nicht
dagegen versichert er will sein haus nun
verkaufen
wir haben ja noch alles wir leben noch
viele menschen stehen noch unter schock
und müssen sich gleichzeitig um das
nötigste kümmern die überlebenden
funktionieren irgendwie in der
katastrophe frage an susanne gelhard vor
ort wie lange wird es dauern bis die
menschen zumindest ansatzweise in ein
normales leben zurück können es wird
wochen dauern bis hier auch nur
ansatzweise wieder normalität einkehrt
im moment sind die menschen froh wenn
sie überhaupt in ihre häuser
zurückkehren können
und sie erwarten jetzt finanzielle hilfe
schnell und unbürokratisch und noch dazu
muss die infrastruktur wieder aufgebaut
werden brücken sind eingestürzt wie hier
hinter mir straßen sind zerstört
bahnlinien sind unterbrochen und die
versorgung mit strom trinkwasser und
mobilfunknetz die funktioniert noch
immer nicht zuverlässig die menschen
hier hoffen auf die zusage der
bundeskanzlerin
und sie hoffen dass die hilfe schnell
und unbürokratisch kommt dankeschön
susanne gelhard
auch in nordrhein-westfalen suchen die
helfer immer noch nach vermissten und
möglichen todesopfern in einigen
gebieten ist die lage weiter kritisch in
erftstadt blessem versuchten anwohner in
ihre häuser zurückzukehren
bislang haben statiker den bereich am
rande eines erdrutsches aber noch nicht
freigegeben
und auch an der steinbachtalsperre bei
euskirchen bleiben ortschaften bis
mindestens morgen gesperrt das wasser
fließt langsamer ab als erwartet
wenn sie den betroffenen helfen möchten
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
ein spendenkonto eingerichtet stichwort
zdf
was er deutschland die iban lautet de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8 190
während im westen das wasser abläuft
kämpfen sachsen und bayern mit neuen
regenmassen besonders betroffen ist das
berchtesgadener land an der grenze zu
österreich meter hoch schoss das wasser
in der nacht durch die straßen
mindestens ein mensch kam ums leben der
landkreis trägt den katastrophenfall aus
helfer und anwohner machten sich direkt
ans aufräumen und es gibt noch keine
entwarnung in den nächsten stunden kann
es weiter heftig regnen
patricia schäfer ist in schönau am
königssee worauf müssen sich die
menschen einstellen
barbara die menschen richten sich hier
auf alles ein viele haben seit gestern
abend seit diesem uhr hier abgegangen
ist man sieht wir autos vergraben wurden
und baumstämme hier festklemmen kein
auge zugetan sind am aufräumen und
trauen sich jetzt auch nicht so richtig
zu schlafen in dieser nacht denn es
regnet weiter und es ist in den alpen
schwierig der deutsche wetterdienst sagt
120 liter pro quadratmeter voraus und in
alpinen gebieten kann das schnell zu
sturzfluten für lokale sturzfluten sind
also noch zu erwarten und schulen und
kitas bleiben sowieso bis morgen
geschlossen
der krisenstab hat bis eben getagt und
man sagte mir bis 23 uhr entscheidet
sich ob noch mal ein starkregen gebiet
eine starkregen zelle berchtesgaden
trifft so lange gibt es hier noch keine
entwarnung
eindrücke aus dem bayrischen
unwettergebiet dankeschön patricia auch
heute gibt es zur flutkatastrophe ein
zdf spezial gleich hier im anschluss und
in unserer heute app geht auch der live
blog weiter mit allen aktuellen
entwicklungen etwa zur kritischen
situation im moment in bayern und auch
das hängt mit der unwetterkatastrophe
zusammen in den sozialen netzwerken
reißt die kritik an nordrhein-westfalens
ministerpräsident laschet nicht ab der
kanzlerkandidat der cdu hatte gestern in
erftstadt mit anderen gescherzt
während vorne bundespräsident steinmeier
zu den betroffenen der fluten sprach auf
twitter entschuldigte sich laschet
später bedauere den eindruck der durch
eine gesprächssituation entstanden sein
zum thema corona trotz steigender zahlen
schließt bundeswirtschaftsminister
altmaier einen neuen look down aus der
bild am sonntag sagte er solange keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems truhe
gebe es keinen grund dafür das robert
koch institut meldet 1292 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages das sind 547 mehr als
vergangenen sonntag drei todesfälle
kamen seit gestern dazu die sieben tage
incident ist wieder zweistellig und
liegt bei 10
corona klimawandel der umgang mit
radikalen kräften in der partei wie
sieht der vorsitzende der afg j leuten
die aktuelle lage gut zwei monate vor
der bundestagswahl unterlagen sie hat
mit jörg leuten gesprochen im zdf
sommerinterview
david guetta hat berichtet wenige tage
nachdem das hochwasser teile von
rheinland-pfalz und nrw verwüstet hat
bekräftigt afg chef jörg merten seine
partei sieht keinen klaren zusammenhang
mit einem sich verändernden klima und
daher auch keinen neuen handlungsbedarf
beim klimaschutz
ich halte es für menschliche hybris so
sagen wir steuern hier das weltklima auf
0,10 zwei grad genau das ist menschlich
für meine begriffe nicht machbar sondern
hier seminar damit umgeht kaum mehr als
zwei monate vor der bundestagswahl
befindet sich die fdp macht und
richtungskampf immer wieder konkret auf
bestimmte radikale auf die kandidaten
auf den listen angesprochen möchten für
diese keine klare wahlempfehlung geben
da sie jetzt bisher keinen dieser
kandidaten unterstützt haben wir haben
noch andere namen christine denen die
ich und stefan brandt jürgen pohl können
sie einen der drei empfehlen für den
bundestag
also da alles nicht meine freunde und
sie wissen es und die empfehlen sie auch
nicht ich habe keine empfehlungen
auszusprechen
dass eine entscheidung der wähler die
auf dem letzten fdp parteitag
beschlossene forderung aus der eu
auszutreten vermuten ein fehler wie auch
die jüngste von einigen als putin an
wiederum kritisierte russland reise
seines co parteichefs copala das ist ein
fehler der sich auch häufiger wiederholt
und ich glaube auch dass in
wahlkampfzeiten relativ wenig sinn hat
auch frau war eine woche vor der
landtagswahl komplett in russland vor
der baden württembergischen landtagswahl
habe ich auch für nicht klug gehalten
kritik an den hfc spitzenkandidaten vom
afw parteichef topleuten dieses amt über
den herbst hinaus behalten möchte lässt
er noch das ganze sommerinterview sehen
sie hier um 19 uhr 25 und jetzt zu
olympia norbert die
hochwasserkatastrophe berührt auch die
deutschen sportler ja im olympischen
dorf in tokio haben athletinnen und
athleten in einer schweigeminute den
opfern der tragödie in der heimat
gedacht das gros des deutschen teams
olympia das ist heute erst nach japan
gestartet lächeln für die kamera aber
gemischte gefühle beim abflug angesichts
der nachrichtlichen gemengelagen 84
deutsche team mitglieder sind heute nach
tokio aufgebrochen noch bevor sie im
olympischen dorf ankommen ist das corona
virus schon da zwei südafrikanische
fußball spieler und ein betreuer sind
positiv getestet von den proben der
eröffnungsfeier wurden heute gerade mal
30 sekunden bildmaterial in die welt
geschickt offensichtliche zurückhaltung
in bezug auf festliche feierstimmung auf
beim veranstalter
formel 1 pilot lewis hamilton hat den
großen preis von großbritannien in
silverstone gewonnen
zu beginn des rennens kollidierten die
wm-rivalen hamilton und spitzenreiter
max verstappen der niederländer raste
mit seinem red bull in die reifenstapel
erstatten konnte seinen zerstörten
boliden aus eigener kraft verlassen und
wurde danach im krankenhaus
durchgecheckt das rennen wurde erst nach
längerer unterbrechung fortgesetzt
der dreimalige alle nur in allen men
weltmeister jan frodeno hat seinen
eigenen weltrekord über die triathlon
langdistanz geradezu pulverisiert beim
tri battle im allgäu gegen den kanadier
allein
das benötigte er für die 3,8 kilometer
schwimmen 180 km radfahren und 42 2
kilometer laufen 7 stunden 27 minuten
und 53 sekunden und unterbot seine fünf
jahre alte bestmarke um mehr als 7
minuten und das ein monat vor seinem
vierzigsten geburtstag der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt weiter vor ergiebigem
dauerregen im südlichen oberbayern
morgen gibt es im norden einige
wolkenfelder im süden ist es länger
sonnig dort sind am nachmittag
vereinzelt gewitter möglich die
temperatur erreicht 18 bis 24 grad im
süden 24 bis 29 grad und das wetter
bleibt auch erstmal so das war es von
uns zum letzten mal aus diesem studio ab
morgen in neuem design wir würden uns
freuen wenn sie bei der premiere dabei
sind hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
zdf spezial in alles gute und bis morgen
wenn sie merken
[Musik]